when the war came to hostimel it was
intense and brutal and grim and many
people died
most of those who could fled the horror
unleashed by the russians here
but max skripnick was not one of them
because in his words he had 600 lives to
protect
the dogs he cares for at the shelter he
runs here
he wanted to make sure they were watered
and fed and not abandoned so he stayed
even as the shells came in
so max this shell landed while you were
here and you were right in the middle of
a battle then yes we even have a chance
to see and to even calculate how many
missiles was on on the ear from
different sites and we even saw these
missiles and it was not dozens it was
hundreds of missiles per day
he stayed for much of the russian
occupation of this village the shelter
owner asia sipinska stayed through all
of it the ukrainian people fulfill their
everyday job and our everyday job to
provide a good life for our animals
and
i hope that we did this job
so frightened with the dogs during the
height of the raging battles they dug
their own holes to escape down when the
noise was too much
some of his animals died the dogs here
died
from the bombarding
or from the heartbreak
when he died
we continue to find the dyed animals
continue to find
he's found a use for the ammunition
boxes left by the russian occupiers who
he persuaded to allow food and a
generator to be brought in to keep the
place going
one six-week-old puppy was born during
the fighting here
she survived
max's priority now is to find homes for
puppies like this and reunite other dogs
with owners who fled
in the midst of war these are people
risking their lives to protect animals
in need it is their duty they say and no
one will persuade them otherwise
mark austin sky news hostimel